how it started and how it's going brain
the computer virus in 1986 two brothers
from Pakistan became very unhappy that
people were pirating the program that
they created then Bassett and amjad
created a program that damaged computers
on which their software was illegally
installed they named this computer virus
brain in order to fix the computer you'd
have to personally call the brothers the
virus very kindly displayed the
necessary contact information on the
screen however brain went on to create
the world's first epidemic by some
estimates it infected about 100 000
computers and that was without the
internet the brothers began to receive
angry phone calls from all around the
world the brain virus epidemic launched
a major revolution in the I.T sector for
example John McCarthy capitalized on the
fight against Brain by creating the
world's first antivirus software and
hence the battle between viruses and
Antivirus began continuing to this day
share this video with your friends and
don't forget to subscribe